[Applause]
in the early hours of September 1st 1939
the German battleship chalets Vikash
Stein attacked a Polish ammunition depot
in Danzig now known as Gdansk
they were the opening shots of world war
ii german bombers also destroyed via
loon but town and western poland of no
strategic importance 1200 civilians were
killed in the vomits first war crime
shortly afterwards the German army
crossed the Polish border a scene
re-enacted for these propaganda pictures
the previous evening SS troops wearing
Polish uniforms had staged an attack on
a German radio station Hitler used this
as a pretext to invade Poland German
troops also attacked the Polish post
office in Danzig the siege lasted
fifteen hours most of the defenders were
shot dead after a German court-martial
but Hitler's ambitions went far beyond
Poland he wanted to conquer Europe and
impose his racist Nazi ideology on the
entire continent the early weeks of the
conflict saw war crimes committed
against polish civilians Poland's allies
Britain and France declared war on
Germany but they were not prepared to
intervene militarily and there was no
help from Moscow the Soviet Union had
given Nazi Germany an almost free hand
Germany and the Soviets had publicly
agreed on a non-aggression pact and
secretly made a deal to carve up Eastern
Europe between the two dictatorships not
long after the German invasion of Poland
the Soviet Union moved in from the east
Poland's fate was sealed when German
forces and the Red Army met at the
agreed demarcation line well now there
are growing demands in Poland for
Germany to pay reparations worth several
billion euros as compensation for the
devastation
country cost the Topix likely to be
raised as Germany's delegation visits
Warsaw on Sunday for commemorations the
question of reparations has caused
tension between Germans and poles
Warsaw's old town a few days before the
80th anniversary of the start of the
Second World War
Leo Mouse Bach walked Sethe route every
day on his way home from work the 29
year old German has lived in Poland for
five years he actively supports German
Polish economic cooperation but he
didn't expect this particular debate
topic to resurface I was surprised when
I heard about Poland's demands for
German reparations and I was seriously
shocked when I saw that many of my
friends young poles who don't sympathize
with the government we're saying that
they could understand why the government
wants this why they feel the Germany has
not yet dealt sufficiently with what
they did
Warsaw's Old Town is a symbol of German
guilt the city was completely destroyed
during the Second World War and then
rebuild without any help from Germany
and now after almost 80 years Berlin is
being handed the bill a parliamentary
committee has been working on a draft
for the government so they can finally
put this topic to rest even though for
decades they have already considered it
closed doesn't like the fact we're
talking about reparations we understand
that but for us it is an important topic
at the moment we are still calculating
the exact reparations sums we want to
present this to Berlin very soon but
Berlin doesn't seem open to this
presentation so far they don't even want
to talk about it the topic is considered
legally closed the other markets in the
Polish government hasn't even sent us an
official message that if they do then
the legal situation requires that we
return to the treaties of 1953 and the
two plus four treaty of 1990 the law
considers these clamps as regulated and
therefore non-existent of the machine
in fact in 1953 communist Poland
renounced reparations from the then
communist East Germany so Berlin
suggested symbolic gestures instead here
for example in the middle of the city
there are plans for a memorial site for
Polish victims of the German occupation
during World War 2 to be built
Leo Massa the young German living in
Warsaw actively supports this idea he
believes that such political gestures
could make the upcoming historical
debates easier I think this would be a
very important sign of compassion it
would be a symbol of empathy for the
poles and a sign that we as Germans
should never forget what happened and
this is why Leo Mouse paw will be here
on Sunday when the presidents of Poland
and Germany remembered the 80th
anniversary of the German invasion